not like us Kendrick Lamar did Kendrick
Lamar just admit that the devil Works
through his and other artists music sent
you down to earth cuz you was broken
Rehabilitation not psychosis but now we
here now centuries you manipulated man
with music embodies you as superar see
how St Lucifer was born into the artist
and then passed away and then came
saying and his performance with the
diamond studded crown of thorns and
blood running down his face that Eerie
portrayal of Jesus is this just artistic
expression or is there something more
Sinister Behind the Music let's check it
out all right Super Bowl
59 I know that this is kind of an
interesting year for the halftime show
Kendrick Lamar is going to do the
halftime show um what do you guys know
about this guy virtually nothing yeah
other than the Drake Krick thing that's
about it you know I I I used to listen
to this kind of music I don't listen to
this stuff anymore so um just doing some
research in this there's something
that's happening here that I think is an
interesting turn we've talked about the
halftime show in the Super Bowl before
plenty of times plenty of time I'm
interested because kendick Lamar he's
kind of interesting in the area of
Christianity yeah now what do you think
about this picture in general it's my
first time seen this guy and it's not a
good impression he left me that's pretty
Blasphemous you know I I I think as you
get into this you'll see a little bit of
a reason why he is performing here um
this this is a person that is outwardly
spoken Christian so he's very vocal he
puts these things in here and I think
what people is that a crown of thorns of
diamonds it is and we're going to get
and we're going to get to that because
it is very weird and uh he has um has
some very interesting lyrics that I want
I want you guys to see because I think
this is this is a a thing that we're
going to start noticing a lot more in
today's world and I think it's not by
chance that he's performing at this
Super Bowl when we have this
Administration that just stepped into
Power oh so anyway um a lot of people
like him because he puts things like
this in there Jesus saves gangsters too
yeah I I I can agree with that Jesus
wants to save everybody I can sentence
in itself it's there's no issue with it
and and I think that you know it's neat
to see somebody that is being very vocal
but is he really does he really care
about your Christianity I think I think
that's what we're going to discuss here
this particular song um he uh I blurred
out this this dancer right here but it's
kind of interesting because he basically
put some Bloods and some Crips in the
same room and he's trying to be all
inclusive and he's sitting here reading
a book what does that say that'll be
like Kendrick for dummies that's kind of
interesting
wow thinks a lot of himself I guess if
he's playing with the idea that he has
the crown of thorns like you saw and
we're supposed to be like
Jesus what's he actually going to start
putting that imagery in out what's
what's he doing this for there's a song
that he wrote called in 95 and I'm going
to just play a couple of Clips here
because this is is kind of the imagery
that he puts in um in some of his videos
here what do you
notice it's a man walking on water yeah
in a crucifix position or above the
water I mean yes can't tell that's him
there's him walking on the water yes in
white which Jesus is
our yeah is this the very next scene
okay no these are taken from um
different different things but this is
all the same song no no no no not same
song the but but this is imagery that
he's starting to play with and it's like
he's embracing that I'm a Gangster but
he's really blending in there this
Christianity MH and to me I I you know
there's seven people there
yeah I know I counted them too and I was
like you know if there was like 12 with
them with bread and wine bottles you
know you know what I mean drunk I don't
think that they're mistaking what
they're trying to put this imagery of or
what they're trying to to say with this
I mean if you're if you say you know
Jesus says gangsters too yes he does and
what is a gangster well it is clearly
somebody who's very violent use a lot of
guns and weapons and U usually engages
in a lot of criminal activity and Jesus
then need if you believe that the Bible
says wants to save you out of that
lifestyle and make him more like him but
in this case that's that doesn't seem to
happen I'm glad you brought that up
because what is Jesus actually trying to
save you from m from our Matthew 1:21 he
call his name Jesus because he will save
the people from their sins so what is
that like when you're like we'll save a
gangster it but you can still be a
gangster it's more like God's Jesus
saves gangsters too but it's more like
God Saves people who used to be saved
people who used to be gangsters cuz once
once you get become saved you have to
change yourself to become more like
Christ because Jesus says if you love me
keep my commands ments and being a
gangster and keeping Commandments don't
really go together they Clash a lot I I
I I I think that some people might bring
up want to bring up and I want to throw
this to you Keith um the Bible verse
about if you call on the name of Jesus
you will be saved you know how how do we
answer that in the larger context of
what the bible really teaches about
salvation yeah this is a really good
question actually I was reading in the
Book of John and I'm preparing to take a
class on on the Book of John because
John goes over some of those themes in
the very first chapter of his book so if
you go to John 1 verse 12 but as many as
received him he gave to them he gave the
right to become children of God to those
who believe in his name and what the
commentary was bringing out I I thought
was fascinating because I had not quite
looked at it this
way before but if you look at this in a
bigger context as it continues to read
it talks about how the word became flesh
dwelt among us we beheld his glory the
glory of his only begotten of the father
right full of grace and truth what does
that remind you of it it reminded me of
something and the commentary brought
this out because I whenever I'd read
this passage I would I would think of
this piece that they mentioned and that
is Exodus like
3334 when Moses asked to see his glory
yes mhm so what they were bringing out
in this is when it says as many as
received him he be he gave the right to
become children of God to those who
believe on his name it wasn't a I just
believe in the name of Jesus its name is
associated with character mhh those who
believe on his
character and in other words there there
is you are coming to identify with that
character in Believing on his name you
become more like him yeah you become
like him because the Bible does talk
about a um a form of godliness but
denying the power which is really like
yeah form of godliness as I'm calling
myself a Christian but it has no power
over my life no there's no conversion no
sanctification no change whatsoever MH
so jumping back here to um these guys
here um he's putting his life
experiences in there kend Lamar grew up
in Compton um which I'm sure is a very
very very rough beginning and so that's
why you see a lot of like gangster stuff
and his art and everything but but
listen to what he says right here about
putting putting these things into these
songs that he had himself has
experienced for me that's what separates
me as as an artist I'm going to give you
the gift and I'm going give you the
curse there for me I'm responsible for
myself to know what I'm talking about
that's what my responsibility come to
know 100% what I'm talking about cuz I'm
a witness it's your choice to listen to
it but it's my responsibility to know
exactly what I'm talking about you know
and to give always give you both sides
of the fence I can't just write I can't
come up with an album if it's not from a
self-experience so I think what people
really like about him is he's super
authentic to the to the music but that's
what people are basically attributing to
him is he's this super unique
everybody's like wow he's just like the
best artist in the world or all this
kind of stuff and here he's putting all
these Christian ideas in there so I
think there's some discussion that's
happening right here in the world where
he's he's putting the name of Jesus in
front of gangster's
Mouse and but I want to show that there
could be a dangerous side of
that when you look at a lot of these
videos that he creates this is just
taken from a video I obviously blurred
this out weird but how weird do you
think it is that he's sitting there in a
room with a bunch of Jesus crosses all
around and he's got some girl man that
is so strange very strange it's it's
there's a lot of imagery that he's
putting these things in there but
alongside with just the the most kind of
vile parts of life these are things that
are in his music videos like Crown Royal
he's glorifying drinking he's glorifying
money he's he's and this particular
music video that this was taken from
right here um I mean when you watch the
music video he's it's it's pretty it's
it's pretty hard to even watch he looks
like he's being possessed it's
interesting he was throwing the money um
I think when Aubrey still worked here
she made a video about who is the
Rainman oh yes you remember that and
that like throwing money was some
reference to the Rainman which has a
reference to Bell which is referen to
Satan so all the prosperity but he's
putting all these these things into his
music videos and um this particular
music video what is the name of the song
God is a gangster wait wait wait so
you're saying God wants to save
gangsters too meaning if God needs to
save you from something you you know
biblically he's saving you from sin and
going make helping you go through the
sanctification process being changed
being becoming a new creature and now
you saying God is a gangster there is
some blurring of lines that's going on
here and wait underneath it's says to
pimp a butterfly album out now yes I
mean what is pimping it means it means
you know you're a pimp you're trying to
like get some prostitutes and sell them
when I was looking up like who is this
trying to understand like what is this
guy like all about it was hard to listen
to even the music there is cussing there
is um you know all sorts of bad things
and so I just kind of turn it off and I
just like look but paying attention to
what he named some of these
songs it's just I think that's
absolutely
Blasphemous it's pretty much saying like
God With Us means he's one of us not
that we should be one with him exactly
it's like almost taking God and
conforming him into a box of what we
think he is like rather than aspiring to
be well what does God want me to be like
I mean there's there's this uh verse
that on in the Bible that says that we
shouldn't be one with the world world
but separate from the world right so why
would Jesus why would God himself be
with the world if he's asking us to you
know come out that's right I I have no
problem with with you know God reaching
to the far ends of the Earth and trying
to win people I hope that he's doing
that I mean I hope that I believe he is
yeah I believe that he is but I hope
that he's reaching the people that are
in the center of Compton and you know
caught up in this whole mess and maybe a
calling out of that lifestyle but not a
glorification of the lifestyle a
gangster is someone that's going to like
basically run the streets so if you're
putting this idea out there that God has
just run in the streets and he's just
like you and me and so like we can still
do that because we're yeah and he's like
pimping a bunch of chicks that's not
yeah that's not changing at all so he
wrote a song called
reincarnated and um it was written from
the perspective of the devil how do you
feel about
that he's writing as if the devil is
working Dre him and we're going to go
ahead and we're going to look at some of
these lyrics that are here because I
think they're very interesting I
highlighted them in two different colors
okay yellow is Kendrick talking and the
red will be what God is saying so I got
this fire burning within me concentrated
thoughts of who I used to be and I'm
shedding the skin truth be told I've
been battling my soul trying to navigate
the real and the fake cynical about
Judgment Day okay what does it mean to
be cynical it means means you're you're
not really um you're like ah it doesn't
really matter like whatever it's just a
joke or you're just like you know like
not positively thinking towards it right
a cynical kind of like a negative
connotation about Judgment Day if you
are on God's side are you going to be
cynical about Judgment Day that means
it's over like we we if you're on God's
side we've won right the only people
that are going to be cynical during
Judgment Day are people not on God's
side so he goes I hear and he says my
father kicked me out of the house wait
wait his father kicked him out of the
house I want you to pay attention to the
language here that I wouldn't listen to
him wouldn't listen to his father so his
father kicks him out I didn't care about
his influence I only loved what I was
doing are you starting to see kind of a
a parallel of a personality here okay
gifted as a musician who got kicked out
by his father didn't want to listen to
him and was a mus yeah San H so let's
read on it says uh the uh the most
talented where I'm from but I had to
rebel and so I'm off to the sunset
searching for my place in the world now
this is paralleling Satan gets kicked
out of heaven he's a musician he Rebels
he's running to and fro on the
earth it says I manipulated power and I
lied to the masses my voice was Angelic
straight from Heaven self- indulged
discipline never been my sentiments who
is
undisciplined doesn't want to follow the
rules doesn't want to like you know his
voice Came From Heaven my daddy looked
the other way he saw sin in
me
now he says my present life is Kendrick
Lamar now let me let me give you a
backstory of what he's kind of basically
saying so in these verses he's starting
to say that this particular character
that is now starting to show up and
that's going to start talking to him has
started out in other artists and he's
now changing when that artist passes
away he's reforming reincarnating as a
new artist and he's now in Kendrick
Lamar possession that's what that's
basically what you would think what like
what he saying this my father kicked me
out of the house I finally forgave him
I'm old enough to understand the way I
was living ego and pride had me looking
at him with resentment I mean this is
literally you could change this out for
the words of of what Satan was saying
against God right as if God needs
forgiveness right I'm yelling father did
I finally get it right everything I did
was selfless now he's going to start
trying to argue with this entity and the
entity says son you do well but your
heart is closed and he says I can't tell
residue that lingers from your past it
creates itself father I'm not perfect I
got urgent but I hold them down but your
pride has to die okay father show me
how so you're going to start to see that
he's going to have this conversation
with this entity now this entity is like
God and and as he's trying to justify
why he's doing what he's doing this is
what that entity starts communicating
with him son you do well but your heart
is closed father I'm not perfect I got
urges but I hold them down but your
pride has to die m i mean what made
Lucifer fall in heaven in the first
place Pride his pride right okay father
show me how now look at that lyric right
there like God deserves to have worship
God deserves to be the king of the
universe and here he's throwing it back
in his face and he's going oh yeah you
want me not to be prideful you show me
how it's done you know and it says tell
me every deed what you've done and what
you did
for I'm trying to I'm trying to push
peace in LA but you love war every
individual is only a version of you how
can they forgive when there's no
forgiveness in your heart that's I mean
that's basically what Satan is trying to
do he's trying to win as many Souls over
to him as he possibly can and make them
more like him God makes Man In His Image
and then wants him to reflect his image
wants him to act like him and the devil
is just copying that and saying no you
need to be like me prideful arrogant you
know King of the Hill this and that and
you can see this battle that's going on
with what he's saying you fell out of
heaven cuz you were anxious didn't like
Authority only searched to be heinous
Isaiah 14 was the only thing that was
prevalent wait a
minute wow you still have any questions
that we talking about here yeah Isaiah
14 Ezekiel 28 that talks about the
casting out of
or at least the origins of why Satan was
cast out which you can see in Revelation
12 and and Isaiah 14 is the pride that
that began to swell in that character's
heart that said I would like to put my
throne above the stars of God and here
he's he's telling him that your my
greatest music director was you it was
colors it was pinks it was Reds it was
Blues it was Harmony and motion and I
sent you down to earth cuz you were
broken
but now here we are centuries you
manipulated man with your music now
think about that I mean he's speaking
the truth he's writing this into the
story it gets a little crazier right
after that because it says embodied you
as
Superstars he's saying it it's like
saying all these people are possessed by
the devil yes that they're being used to
manipulate man kind yeah I find that
fascinating so it ends with this you
crushed a lot of people keeping their
thoughts in captivity just ponder that
line for a
second Satan wants to put his thoughts
in your mind that's why the Bible tells
us let this mind be in you that was also
in Christ Jesus G God wants our thoughts
and all of our thinking to be thinking
uh in the Captivity of Christ they're at
War right now trying to put each each of
those either God's putting his thoughts
in your mind or the devil's putting his
thoughts in your mind and it says I
rewrote the devil's story just to take
our power back
carnated I think we're engaged in a very
dark war MH and what you're going to see
coming out in the end of time is a
version of godliness that is sold to the
general
population but with no change of heart
mhm he has a song that um that he wrote
on Mr morale and um uh you'll see some
clips of him talking about this but what
do you see on his
head crown of thorns but it looks
expensive you know what it reminds me of
we did a show uh we recorded a show a
couple of weeks ago I can't remember
which one it was called but it was
showing a a picture of um the during the
time of the Reformation of the Dark Ages
where you had Jesus Jesus riding a a
lowly donkey on one side and it was like
the pope at the time on like with like
all his regalia and and Rich expensive
clothes and this is the same thing Jesus
genuinely had a dirty crown of thorns on
his head that genuinely pierced his head
and this is just like the opposite of
like like I'm kind of like Jesus but I'm
rich and wealthy you know if you knew
what Jesus before he was reincarnated
and came down here to be a human being
if you saw him wearing a head of crown a
crown in heaven you probably couldn't
even look at it it'd be so bright and
shiny he has this amazing beautiful
crown mhm he traded that for a crown of
thorns taking the lowest and most humble
thing that he possibly could do and to
me putting diamonds on a Crown is
absolutely Blasphemous well that Crown
was meant to mock him yeah took put it
there to mock him took the word Crown a
bit too serious so here's what he says
why he's wearing the crown listen to
this so many faces y'all bless me to be
up on this
stage and we make sure we blessed to
give y'all some [__] you can feel and
that's the real reason why I wrote Mr
morale because everybody's going through
something no matter what you're going
through imperfection is beautiful
I wear this Crown they judge
Christ they judge you they judge Christ
they judge you they judge Christ I wear
this as a representation so you'll never
forget one of the greatest prophets that
ever walk to
Earth what do you think wait he says
they judge you they judge Christ M
mhm I have a problem putting him in the
same ve as all the other
prophets that's God that's what I was
thinking that's God and he listens to a
lot of eart toi eart to's constantly
like talking about the ascended
different Masters new and yeah it's new
age it's a new age view of Jesus and so
for him to put him on that same kind of
Level Playing Field is basically he's
just one of them he's not he didn't say
that's God mhm so greatest Prophet yes
and then what did he say imperfection is
beautiful mhm again that's the opposite
of what Jesus wants to do say make us
perfect be perfect because my Father in
Heaven is perfect he says me and the
father are one which means Jesus was
also perfect yes and he was God he's
wanting to restore man into that not
embracing let's celebrate our
imperfection and our Brokenness this is
selling a version of Jesus to the
population that has no change in your
character whatsoever it fact it
celebrates your broken parts yeah the
contingent in Romans
7 is you know at the end it's like oh
Wretched Man that I am who can deliver
me from this body of death it's not like
you know what I'm broken but let's
celebrate that you know what I mean so
should I continue in sin God forbid no
like I need to be changed and this is
literally celebrating that so during
this performance he's dancing around he
has this Crown of Thorns notice there
blood on his shirt he has blood dripping
down his face so he's now taking this
very like like strong imagery that's
right here he has a big black mirror
behind him that's why you can't see the
full Crown of Thorns he has his light
shining down and then you've got these
redbed beans dancing around him and he's
kind of flipping back and forth between
having these white dancers and then
having these like red dancers come in so
I'm assuming that he's like talking
about this battle but what does it say
right here on the screen I'm not not
your
savior to wear a crown of thorns with a
light shining down from heaven above and
you are putting the imagery out there
that is literally taking the the imagery
of the Christian Pinnacle thing of Jesus
being crucified on the cross and then
putting the words I your savior I am not
you just are burning into people's minds
that that's not your savior it's a such
a a weird thing to do yeah I find that
totally Blasphemous I know I know I
don't know if this is kind of weird but
it genuinely actually makes me emotional
to see this doesn't it and and and when
people sit there and like oh you guys
don't know what you're talking about
this this is a Christian I saw tons of
people defending this guy this is this
is this is dark evil I'm just thinking
about like like when you really get to
know Jesus you know and you really
realize what he's done for
you like it hurts to me to see somebody
do this to our Savior and make to be
this Blossom and make a diamond studded
element out of that you know the tons of
rappers wear crosses on their chest and
and we'll get to that Tiffany did this
Crown of Thorns 8,000 diamonds on this
corn on this this this Crown of Thorns
8,000 diamonds and to wear that around
as a symbol I think is an absolute
mockery to what God did Workshop
Northern Italy right you know it's just
like yeah that's a whole another show
here's them this is on Tiffany's website
right here they show you what went into
this we're talking a year and a team of
people spread out over 10 months to make
this Crown of Thorns that's some serious
energy yeah yeah dude
all right that's not the first celebrity
that's ever mocked Jesus on stage so I
want to show you a I want to show you
some common parallels unfortunately it
won't be the last yes Madonna has been
this blatantly Blasphemous as well
putting herself on the cross and during
this performance she comes down off of
the Cross which is once again a very
Blasphemous thing to do but I I'm
completely offended by this and you know
to see another rapper just Towing that
line and and using that imagery um in
such a such a Blasphemous way is is is
hurtful I'd agree with you um Kanye West
and JayZ I don't know if you remember
the he had a song called H to the iso V
to the is and that was the his way his
name is Jay and he's talking that he's
Jehovah MH God complex and you know
Kanye West is
yeesus Christ and you know changing his
name to ye is is is was was just kind of
interesting I think one of the first
albums Kanye West put out he was
actually sitting on this throne and
there was like this demonic creature
sitting next to him with a black ground
and a red hand um which is clearly
referes to Satan that was one of the
first ones at things where he came out
saying I am yeus which is again just
contradicting itself right he came on
the cover of Rolling Stone and uh was
wearing a crown of thorns this is a
picture that kind passed around and and
okay I'm just going to say this is when
he was in his sort of debaucherous state
right he's you know doing this not
necessarily maybe from the Christian
Perspective that he has claimed he has
turned into um Madonna was on the cover
of Vogue magazine dressed up as the
Catholic Mary but then she also had a
picture where she was like also the last
supper also for Vogue magazine with a
bunch of women around her and the trans
woman who were apparently the disciples
and there was like you know a lady just
literally having her breast sticking out
and I'm it was really really V here is
Kanye West in
2024 so this is just being interviewed
not very long ago at all and you know he
did his whole Christianity thing and now
he's kind of like coming back out listen
to what he says right here so I'll be
surprised that I'm still alive every day
how did you not soal
disappeared like cuz that's a hell of a
fight cuz you know cuz I'm God and
anyone to disagree I'm the god of me and
you can't tell me who I am I can't tell
y'all I could tell y'all it's y'all job
to listen I'm the god of me I don't know
if I'm in heaven already I got number
one from that how you know I might be in
like a fourth dimension version of the
lifestylist
got straight weird what happened to
Jesus's King yeah I mean it's like he's
kind of taking a little bit of a turn
going back out into left field and
making ye porn and whatever he's he's
he's cooking up like if you really truly
are converted in the heart you're going
to see the fruit of the conversion in
your body of work right he's this isn't
the first time he's said this I mean he
he's come out publicly lots of times
over the years saying the same kind of
the reason why I made the song I am a
god is so those people that feel less
then can turn it up and say it loud and
embrace it for themselves we are the
kingdom and I'm the head of the Kingdom
I am God no one can suggest to me period
wow you can't tell my daughter that to
me about Jesus I'm just tell you some
real simp God runs the world I am God I
on the world I am a god everybody says
who does he think he is I just told you
who I thought I was a God I just told
you that's who I think I
am I really wonder if this guy is
possessed to be honest with you because
he's like I am God and I run this world
let me know who the God of this world is
you know I think that there is a lot of
confusion at that level of Fame I I can
only imagine like you know this is
something that Michael Jackson
experienced right he saw the very tippy
top of the iceberg and your reality
becomes bent mhm and when you start like
you know and I think a dangerous
position to be in is to then tell
everybody in the world I'm Christian now
and you know it's all about Jesus as
king and and and and then you fall off
that wagon mhm and you've got like a lot
of people paying attention to you now
that are trying to like you know when we
when we first saw this when years ago
when we first came out we we were like
people in the comment section were awful
to us whatever leave him alone he's
totally a Christian and then you see him
kind of going backwards like this Ariana
Grande also says that God is a woman but
then in the music video it's like I
think it's Michelangelo who made that
painting of like God and Adam touching
and it's like she's
God in Revelation when it says here are
the here's the patience of the Saints
here are those who have keep the
Commandments and have the testimony of
Jesus it doesn't
say that God's end time people are
just professing Jesus when you look at
that it it when it says they keep the
Commandments of God and that this is not
in any way suggesting that they're doing
it in their own strength but they the
fruit of their lives is
Holiness and when it says they have the
testimony of Jesus in other
words they're testifying about the
goodness of God and what he's done in
their lives how he brought them to the
point where he can live in and through
them so they can keep those Commandments
and it has nothing to do with like you
know just declaring yourself just or
righteous or anything like that it's all
about what God is doing for you and
that's
demonstrated and it's demonstrated for
the world at the end of time it's not
just it's not just signing a petition or
putting your hand up and saying I'm part
of this group in the very beginning of
the Bible we have a story of the very
first time two people were called to
worship God in a certain particular way
one of them Cain didn't want to follow
orders right Abel followed orders to a
te and what happened out of that
experience Cain wasn't worshiping Satan
right then he wasn't saying I don't want
to I I don't want to um I want to
worship this false deity he's trying to
worship God in his own way which was
outside of the box of what God Said and
so this is what I see happening L there
are a lot of
these um people that are I mean if you
saw them on the street they' tell you
I'm a Christian I believe in God MH but
where does that fruit lead listen to
what he says right here it's like why
should you fear you know it's another
thing I don't like a Christianity the
fear of God if God is love why should
you fear
him I don't think he understands what
that means no yes I don't think that he
understands because when you look at
what the Bible actually says that go
ahead and read this think the fear of
the Lord is the beginning of wisdom
fools despise wisdom and
instruction fear the Bible's not talking
about to be scared of the Bible's
talking about you to respect that person
reverence yeah reverence if I'm standing
at the edge of a precipice or a cliff
and and if I step off that cliff and I'm
going to die you better bet I'm going to
have a healthy amount of fear that's
going to be like I respect the edge and
I can stand back here right and so
there's there's the the fatherly aspect
of it as well I mean my dad I'm sure he
loves me and I love him but I'll still
fear and respect him especially when I
was younger I was you know quite the
sometimes I would get in trouble and
stuff I feared his reaction but I still
loved him and I knew he loved me too so
even if it is actually fear from like
the the being afraid aspect it doesn't
change who God is as a an all loving God
right perfect uh perfect love casts out
fear right M um Keith go ahead and read
this the fear of the Lord is hatred of
evil pride and arrogance and the way of
evil and perverted speech I hate I think
that's a fascinating verse to think that
God hates something because we actually
always talk about the love of God love
God's just love and and especially the
world is getting touted this version of
God that he's just going to love you and
and everyone's going to make it you know
in the end despite what they act like
what is another word for evil it's
iniquity it's sin well according to the
Bible what is it the definition of sin
sin is the transgression of the law
meaning the ten commandments so the fear
of the Lord is hatred of God's ten
commandments being violated God's ten
commandments which is a reflection of
his character one more go ahead and read
that FIP and he said to men behold the
fear of the Lord that is wisdom and to
turn away from Evil is understanding so
do you notice how what a the Bible
describes as a healthy fear of the Lord
is to turn away from things that are
evil to not engage in those kind of
activities why because you you respect
God's asking mhm and I think that's a
healthy view of fear oh I know what this
is something please tell tell us what
this is I mean this was uh Kanye I think
Justin Bieber was there too but he's on
the rooftop performing and it's uh
Marilyn Manson yes is there so Mar marn
Manson is there Marilyn Manson is the
guy that's at the um at the uh
microphone right here and then Kanye is
over here in front of the yeah there's
there's some very interesting people
that attended this Sunday service yeah
it was a Sunday service isn't Marilyn
menson like a minister of the Church of
Satan in his concerts he rips up the
Bible and he will um burn it he'll throw
feces on it he does not like God in the
slightest so what kind of service is
this a Sunday service it's a worship a
church so this is what he was doing in
his Sunday service now now what caught
my attention with this is that he would
performed this particular one on October
31st and so that was kind of a yeah that
was kind of a very interesting thing so
you know what The Druids
are you know in England the Stonehenge
and the people that did that oh they
often had their worship of their pagan
gods on October 31st which was Halloween
this is what they look like that's what
they look like and so I just Googled
what do The Druids wear during a druid
worship ceremony and look at the
pictures and then please tell me that
Kanye West is not messing with the same
thing wow come on straight weird here's
why somebody just saying I believe in
Jesus and that's it doesn't work it
doesn't
work these two things are alarmingly
close to together on the same day but
let's you know
hey I I'll move on just for the sake of
of trying to get through this 1 John 1:6
says if we say that we have fellowship
with him and we walk in darkness we lie
and we do not practice the truth so
that's why the Bible says that um you
know what Fellowship do these things
have
together yeah and in in Matthew 7 it
says not everyone who comes comes to me
saying Lord Lord shall enter the Kingdom
of Heaven M right and when you look at
that passage he he he clearly you know
talks about those who are
um uh he talks about them being
Lawless yep and so you know it's
demonstratable fruit right it's not just
profession it's so true so let's look at
a few other um very interesting
celebrities that um all have a claim to
believe in God do you think Snoop Dog's
a
Christian uh don't think so all right so
he was asked the question what does God
mean to you listen to what he says so
Snoop I have to ask you this spiritual
question right what does God mean to you
and what is your inspiration in your own
work um God is everything to me without
God I'm nothing I couldn't exist without
him and I keep him in everything I
do Snoop keeps him in everything that he
does I keep thinking of his of his song
uh so what we do we so what we do drugs
I mean we're just having fun we're wild
and free a lot of his music glorifies
the gangster life style and pimping
girls and smoking weed and all those
kind of things um I this really
interesting he was asked um this
question about believing in the devil
listen to what he says do you believe in
the devil definitely what do you think
the devil is like
president he's making this during the
Trump Administration he's probably
linking it to that yes but but I thought
that was interesting that he said
president just not a president or this
president he's like King of the Hill
right here's Snoop actually talking
about when he wrote the song Murder um
um murder was the case listen to what he
says murder was
the
damn that was about me losing my life
but before I lost my life I did cut a
deal with the
devil but then God came back and gave me
another chance that was in my mind but
when I wrote it just became some
gangster but that was the premise
behind isn't that interesting MH I mean
I find it interesting that he wrote a
song but he's literally saying that I
sold my soul to the devil but he
mentions then that God gave him a second
chance and he didn't write that into
this song Katy Perry says the same thing
you know I grew up a Christian want to
make him the music industry sold my soul
to the devil and then there's also they
actually wrote a Netflix uh created a
Netflix documentary about this guy can't
remember his name but everybody around
him said he sucked at playing the guitar
he was bad and then all of a sudden this
is like 40s 50s he went to the
crossroads so his soul to the devil and
then he became this amazing Music
musician and they're like how did you do
that he's like you know and there are so
many artists that go back to that same
Crossroad I know the story you're
talking about I don't remember his name
yeah I'm not going to remember his name
off the top of my head too but when he
came back he he like came back a month
later and could play amazingly yeah um
Lady Gaga um you know she claims that
she is a believer in God as well and
they made a documentary when she was
kind of rising to fame and they were
showing her in a dressing room and she
would say these prayers she would get
everybody in the room to pray together
listen
this
pray Lord thank you so much for the
blessings of all my friends and my
family dear Lord thank you so much for
bringing us here today we feel so
humbled every day that we get to
experience what we experience on this
stage isn't that I find that fascinating
because during some of these concerts
and if to analyze her music as well it's
just full of of terrible things she
calls her fans their little monsters and
this and that it's not not glorifying
God in any way shape or form but they
really do I mean that could have been a
prayer to God or it could have been a
prayer to anyone you're calling Lord so
I I don't believe that we're worshiping
the same God MH as what she is Katy
Perry does the same thing before her
Super Bowl performance she prayed a
prayer and then she has all this like
Masonic imagery in her Super Bowl it's
it's strange here is a clip of her
riding in the cars and the people that
are in the back seat are asking her you
know you just all of a sudden got all
this Fame out of nowhere where did you
where did this come from and she's
trying to answer this
question how did this
happen how did this how did who created
this because I I didn't create this I
for sure didn't it's it's God it's for
sure Jesus it ain't me because
I'm not ridiculous enough to think for a
second that I'm that
powerful so she's even attributing her
Fame to God put her in that position
Jesus put her in that position and gave
her that and it's like I don't know if
you ever seen any of the music videos
that she was on but did you see the one
with um uh I think we put it in the in
the breakdown that we had with her but
she's riding on the back of the
motorcycle with Jesus and she's staring
at Judas and she really wants Judas
in love with Judas that's what she sings
if you really loved God would you even
would that even remotely float through
your brain no wow so I think there's an
interesting mix of people this is Katie
Perry as she was going to be on the
Super Bowl and they made a documentary
about her backstage too and she gathers
everybody together for prayer and before
the show on Sunday uh there will be a a
communal prayer just to surround
ourselves with some
protection let's do a quick prayer I
pray God that you will look after us
thank you so much for this incredible
opportunity and we know it's because of
you cuz you have chosen us and we
believe that we are exactly where where
we are supposed to be today at this
moment and we will be present and
conscious and we will smile and we will
live in this 12 and 1 half
minute now can anybody tell
me right after this
prayer she goes out on stage right a
beast or something what is she
singing that was Dark Horse where she
talks about playing with magic he sings
this she sings this song with Lenny
Kravitz I kissed a girl and I liked it
oh yeah why would you pray to God please
protect us so that I can go out there on
the big stage known in our country and
literally promote anti-
biblically ideas yeah I wonder what you
know what do you what do you say to God
at the end of all
things yeah sorry God I I was just
pretending I mean you know on the one
hand one could make the argument you
know just for argument sake what if God
did put them in that position just like
he's giving them a talent right and then
at the end of the day he's like well
what did what did you do with it yeah
and they they have to answer for that
just like everybody else and I'm not
saying you know one way or the other I'm
just saying it's an
interesting process to Think Through
like there's different you know people
will use that same application where
like different people that are set up as
rulers and stuff you think about
Nebuchadnezzar had the option to reject
God probably almost
did he did when he threw the three boys
in the in the fire F then fli around
real quick at the end you know you find
that he he does admit but I think that's
the difference like there's a change and
with these kind of things it doesn't
seem like there's any change like why
why would you give God the credit and
then do stuff that's the opposite like
it just doesn't make sense but yeah yeah
I mean especially in Katy Perry's um you
know example because she did talk about
her Christian upbringing and when she
first came into this you know she had a
lot of like belief I don't know what
kind of uh denomination yeah if she if
she had a very fearful view of God I'm
sure it was you know maybe maybe
something that contributed to her and
she meets all these other people and
like finds out hey they're not really
like what I what I thought they were
like you know and they're kind of nice
and you know that could e easily
influence you as well but um Matthew
7:21 Keith you said this verse so go
ahead and read that not everyone who
says to me Lord Lord shall enter the
kingdom of heaven but he who does the
will of my father Father in heaven
what's the key of this verse doing God's
will it isn't necessarily calling lord
lord it's doing the will of God and what
is the will of God when somebody came up
to Jesus and was like you know how do I
get into heaven how did Jesus answer
that who is this
Felipe Beyonce Beyonce now she started
out as a Christian y yep so you talked
about her in the in the last show she
was yeah someone else who was always
thinking in the church and decided to I
don't find this um out of the beginning
stages of her um um experience in there
in Hollywood too but she was asked about
her relationship with God listen to what
she says what's your relationship to God
I'm sorry what's your relationship to
God With God God Is My Everything he's
he created everybody everything and I
love him and he is the reason why I sing
so in the beginning stages I'm going to
give her the benefit the doubt she
probably was trying to blend both of
those worlds together it's quite a
different story today I mean you hear
like some of the things that are coming
out about her now this was actually on
um Inside Edition and uh they're talking
about a lawsuit that was filed against
Beyonce Beyonce is the top earning woman
in music she makes around $105 million
or at least she did last year so along
with all those riches Fame also also
brings bizarre allegations like the lady
who went to court accusing Beyonce of
practicing extreme
witchcraft in heads scratching court
papers Kimberly Thompson a former
drummer for the singer's all girl band
is accusing Beyonce of get this extreme
Witchcraft and magic spells and the
murder of my pet cat she's actually
filed a restraining order against the
star sounds kooky right and that's
probably why a judge immediately denied
Thompson's request for a restraining
order there's always been Whispers that
Beyonce belongs to some kind of secret
society they point to hand signals like
this as an example of her communicating
cryptic messages but the accusations of
Witchcraft take things to a whole new
strange level so let's say you got your
news from Inside Edition the the
insinuation of her voice makes you think
what this just a joke this is just
stupid to believe this that's right you
are that's a bizarre belief and how dare
people think that this is ridiculous
just just because she's famous people
are having these accusations just
because her cat died she has to blame it
on someone yeah like you know if if it
if it if it smells like a it looks like
a I'm pretty much going to say that it's
probably close to that and if you have
multiple accusations coming at you from
these points of of of common
denominators here and I mean she she
Beyonce talks about it herself we talked
about in in in the last show where she
doesn't she doesn't even go out and sing
anymore she has this Alter Ego that goes
up yeah right and this is something
pretty common in witchcraft working with
other you know Spiritual Beings to take
over and do things for you yeah there
there's some um uh there's this
interview is very fascinating the guy
that you're seeing here on the left um
he was actually in training to be a
warlock
warlock is like a male witch and this
guy was involved in the occult as well
and um so he's talking about his
experience he went down to New Orleans
once when he was going to um be trained
up as a warlock and it's very
interesting who walked into the
witchcraft store that he was in listen
to this I wanted to ask you too cuz we
talked about this a lot in the last
podcast but we didn't really get into
specifics you obviously were you know
practicing Voodoo at one point you're
thinking a dual induc warlock if I'm not
misten
right I saw a tattoo of p didy and I
think it was like a deity that people in
Voodoo worship right and a lot of people
see the whole py thing that's going on
and they don't understand how spiritual
it is and how a lot of people you know
are in the occult that are in Hollywood
that's actually part of my testimony but
you were in a lot of these circles uh
with with celebrities if I'm not
mistaken that we also doing this yes sir
do you can you name like any maybe
people that are really popular where
they've been in similar Circles of that
Voodoo with you yes sir so Salange knows
bro I'll never forget it I'm in New
Orleans New Orleans and I'm with this uh
warlock that's training me up that's the
one that was going to dual induct me in
Puerto Rico and in Haiti so you know
he's telling me hey you know in OCT oer
crazy in October during Halloween time
yeah don't celebrate Halloween he's like
hey we're going to go to Puerto Rico and
Haiti Haiti first you're going to you're
going to stay in the cemetery for a week
yeah you're going to get induct you know
ordained or inducted and then go to
Puerto Rico be dual inducted into voodo
and santoria I'm thinking this is my
calling I'm like kind of like not sure
at the time I'm like huh he's like yes
you don't you're Puerto Rican this is
your roots this is your ancestors all
this stuff and I'm thinking maybe but
then bro this is what like I believe
like took my faith to the next level to
believe it's true yeah is I'm in this
little it's called a Botanica Botanica
like a little witchcraft store like in
New Orleans in the cut and I'm behind
the register with him the you know the
the shrine like the whole altar all that
stuff is is behind that door so you know
I was in there earlier talking to him
I'm now behind the register he's taking
customers just just training me
discipling me and uh you know I see
someone walk through the door I look to
my left it's Salange NOS wow Beyonce
sister Beyonce's sister bro wow blood
sister and I'm looking like is this real
yeah like nah this ain't Salange bro
this Ain I'm looking she's grabbing
items so she's grabbing like all these
witchcraft items to purchase and she's
grabbing this item grabbing this item
you got her uh her boyfriend trailing
her this trender Adan dude he has these
shades on he's kind of like a little
nervous he's just like not really
involved I looked I looked it up later
that actually was her boyfriend I don't
know if it still is MH remember when she
dropped that album and went viral yeah
so this is right before this happened
wow remember when she was like not even
known and then out of out of nowhere she
came out with the album and it just blew
up yeah and like and she was she got put
on so this is right before all that
happened wow so I'm like is this Salan
no this this can't be Salange and I'm
like okay this is this this has to be
and I asked the guy you know the the
Santo the Warlock is that Salan he's
like yeah she comes here all the time so
casual and I'm just like bro are you see
he's like yeah so many celebrities come
here we do rituals for her all the time
we do work for her all the
time I mean all the time I think there
is a
pretty substantial amount of evidence
with some of these musicians that are
out in the world right now that have
been dabbling in witchcraft MH and and
what's scary is I've even seen video
clips of guys that that that talk about
being in the rooms um with the the
record labels that prey over the records
as they go out into the world so that
they can do their work with those people
what does that mean when we're listening
to these people's music if you're paying
attention to what they're doing and
you're following these celebrities I
mean these guys are straight into
witchcraft I mean that's not just a
image that they're putting out there
that that's really their lifestyle mhh
and you it doesn't necessarily we were
talking about Kendrick Lamar at first
and I think he does rap right yeah but
it's not only rap that does that any
type of music I mean and and sometimes
it can even be used for good right in
this in the Bible we have the story of
Saul when he was tormented by demons and
Saul's servant went and fetched David
and David came and started playing the
harp and that was the cure for it right
and then David got hired to keep playing
the harp so we can see the music does
have an
influence uh against demons but it also
means that it can have two call demons
in yep if it can push him away you can
bring him in in an invitation right so I
thought this was pretty fascinating um P
did you think he's a
Christian no come on they're all
Christian the headlines we suggest
otherwise okay so he wrote an album
called The Love Al album and listen to
what he says just got that call one day
from God and she was like it's it's time
her voice sounds way better than that
though more Godly though but it was God
as a woman so she was like it's time and
I was like it's time whoa what voices
are you hearing yeah I I think he's got
Su glasses on for a reason I think he's
probably blitzed out of his mind at this
point um but I found lots of videos of
him doing this he's there's tons of
videos of him wearing crosses and
talking about it
and you know how many rappers acrosses
so to me that doesn't mean a thing I'm
I'm I'm throwing that out there because
that is exactly what I think too I think
that is it is a symbol that we believe
that God had had used to purchase
Humanity back and they're using it as a
like a cool factor and and it's usually
covered with bling bling yeah it's not
the same thing here is him talking about
um um doing things for God T start show
3 years ago
God made my mission and my purpose clear
and my mission and my purpose is to do
whatever and play whatever role that I
have to play and saving the black race
number one and number two to making sure
that everybody of all colors all
backgrounds all Creeds all nationalities
all get this we all get the same 24
hours not just one race not just another
race not just one gender not another we
all get the same 24 hours but I'm
fighting this fight and to other people
it's an Impossible Dream it's not
impossible it's going to happen we're
going to make progress and change the
world but I can't do it alone and I know
there's people that feel just like me
that are out there that are talented
that's probably working for Google or
Nike or working for bigger corporations
that have a track record and have an
experience at the level that I'm playing
at I'm not coming to just compete I'm
coming to win I'm going to buy Disney
for us okay so if you are one of these
unicorn Executives please send me your
resumés in your portfolios anyway you
get the picture I I wonder what those
people would think who've been his
victims at the freak freak offs and then
who see this they're going to be like no
dude no your actions have to match your
profession your profession of you
believe in God it's the devil believes
in God the devil knows that God's real
he's not going to get saved and so you
know this is where the rubber meets the
road it's like as we are coming into
these final moments in Earth's history
God is wanting a group of people that
love not their lives even unto death
where are these people that that say
they are followers of Christ and their
life reflects that well another thing is
that I the way this really
destroys the image of God is that you
know how you know how many people are
out there who say I'm not a Christian
because you know I had a father figure
or I had this person who say they were a
Christian or whatever but they didn't
act the part I know people like that
were out of the church left the church
over that um and and so yeah when you
have all of these people claiming the
name of Jesus but don't show the fruits
of a converted heart these people you're
like why would I worship your God your
God has no power which so many people
have come to Christ completely changed
their life around my myself being one of
I wasn't always a Christian you you were
in Hollywood I mean we all have our
stories you know Jesus was very selfless
I mean just in that last interview we
just saw with him I'm going to win you
know it's like that you never you never
saw Jesus coming at that level he was he
was always humble and you know would go
give his shirt off of his back for
somebody else and and and to see that
stark contrast with with the luxury and
the you know the the the imagery that
the rap game promotes like I got to get
mine before you got to get yours it's me
first you you last you know it's just
it's not a Christlike character at all
Matthew 158 and N says these people
honor me with their lips but their
hearts are far from me they worship me
in v Vin their teachings are mere human
rules and I know that this is talking
about you know the the class of
Pharisees but this is also the example
that the Pharisees had they were
claiming we're Christian we we are
followers of God and yet they're
lifestyle was a empty whitewash
seler filthy inside I think that God is
calling us to a higher standard than
this that's why the miter on Jesus says
Holiness to the Lord right it's it's
Holiness is a very important thing to
God we talked about this earlier many
will say to me Lord Lord and that day
have we not prophesied in your name cast
out demons in your name have we not done
many Wonder Works in your in your name
the thing I want to dredge out about
this too is this isn't talking about the
rappers this isn't talking about a class
of people who could care less about God
and were just doing whatever they wanted
to do in the earth these are people that
were professing to follow God and do
things in God's name it's Christians
Christians this is this is a wakeup call
because God has to tell them and the end
depart from me I never knew you you
workers who practice lawlessness what is
lawlessness not following the Ten
Commandments yeah sin is a transgression
of the law yeah not loving God with all
your mind your heart and your soul and
loving your neighbor as yourself those
two the whole law hangs on those two
concepts right there doesn't mean we
shouldn't keep keep the Ten Commandments
the because some people say oh the that
verse right there that uh the
Fulfillment of the law the whole of law
is um love God and love man and then
they're like oh that's all we have to do
like no no no no that is pointing back
to the Ten Commandments
correct um here is the last verse we'll
finish off with this one go ahead and
read this denique a good tree cannot
bear bad fruit nor can a bad tree bear
good fruit every tree that does not bear
good fruit is cut down and thrown into
the fire what is the
saying both things have to
match you can't talk
about fruit I mean if you've ever eaten
a piece of fruit from a tree that did
not produce good fruit right what's the
point of the tree chop it down and start
another one because it's not it's
unfruitful it's not even it's not even
worth it's taking up water it's you know
it's it's not worth anything and I think
that this verse right here and and
remember this is Jesus saying this right
so he's letting us know that our mission
in life what we are all called to do is
to be shining lights for him to love our
neighbors to do good to those that hate
us to to go out of our way and to make
someone's existence more um better and
to bless other people and stuff like
that that's that's showing the fruit and
I'm I'm not saying that these rappers
they don't like give money to
organizations and stuff like that but
I'm just saying if what they're
promoting in their music does not match
what they are professing to believe in
there's a
problem all right Felipe finish us off
of this one Ephesians 5:1 and have no
fellowship with the unfruitful works of
darkness but rather expose them having
no fellowship with the unfruitful works
of darkness does not mean listen to the
music music and play uh play them over
and over and over in your head I I
really honestly believe that if these
things are talking about dark evil stay
away from it that would be that would be
what the Bible I believe um suggests
you're starting to see a lot of stuff
come out in the public right now
exposing some of these things I think
it's becoming increasingly um harder for
the devil to hide behind these doors and
as we're starting to see more and more
people supposedly turn to
Christianity what kind of Christian are
we saying we are does your does your
actions match what you believe and I'm I
believe that that is a call for all of
us we should reflect on that and um if
if you know you have things in your life
or your your experience um labor those
with God say you know Lord I don't know
how to do this but you know give me give
me your words give me your actions give
me your thoughts and uh you'll see God
can totally transform your life um we
hope you guys were blessed by this uh
content I'd love to hear your thoughts
if you've seen any of these or you um
have any things that we might have
missed write it down in the section
below and and um if you haven't seen any
of our other videos check them out we've
got a lot of videos that that talk about
these kind of subjects um but as always
um we're sharing biblical truth and uh
look it up for yourself make sure what
we're saying is actually what the Bible
is saying and um we hope you guys will
uh stop by again and give this video a
thumbs up subscribe if you haven't
subscribed but uh we'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]